wird iBlali demnächst anfangen zu rappen
und ist er tatsächlich so geldgeil wie
in dem einen oder anderen Kommentar
unterstellt wird das und viel mehr jetzt
im fragenlotte und wenn er nichts von
ihm und demnächst von Hansi dem
deutschen Chuck Norris verpassen wollt
dann abonnieren nicht vergessen bis dann
bleib
dran das ist das ja was soll ich dazu
sagen das Fragenlotto
genau und da sind sie jetzt die bösen
gemeinen harmlosen und so weiter Fragen
und was mit den Grünen die sind doch
eigentlich lieb oder die sind harmlos
das sind die harmlos das sind die
harmlosen also du kannst wählen und so
weiter und so forort kenst gut fangen
wir
an ja die Grünen sind ja langweilig also
wirklich ja aber die pass auf die Grünen
stecken wir die meiste Mühe rein wobei
die W trotzdem immer doof weil die sind
so schwer die roten
dagegen das ist wirklich eine gemeine
Frage ja magst du Bratwurst
m na ja ich habe siewar schon mal antwor
aber ja ich mag Bratwurst ich mag
wirklich gerne Bratwurst ich liebe
Bratwurst okay und die Frage die Frage
ob ich die Bratwurst mag nein diese
Frage wie oft hast du die inzwischen
gehört wie oft die gehört habe gute
Frage wie oft habe ich die gehört also
ich höre ich seit Mitte 2010 hö ich die
schon mindestens dazu könnte man
eigentlich auch ein Quiz machen genau
wie oft Gott das ist eine schwierige
Recherche das ist eine wirklich
schwierige Recherche mindestens 500 mal
wirklich mindestens also mindestens 500
bis 1000 mal gehört
es kam dadurch dass ich auf Alligator
C24 ein abonnentenpal hochgeladen habe
das war das 1000 Abonnenten Special und
D habe ich einen Freund gefragt die hieß
ncolas balina auf Youtube ob er mir eine
sinnvolle also eine sinnlose Frage
stellen kann einfach nur für den Witz so
und das war die einzige Frage die ich
beantwortet habe magst du bratwur habe
ich mit ja beantwortet und dadurch ist
es explodiert okay das ist quasi dein
wann kommt Kronk richtig das kannte man
so sagen deswegen kann ich dich auch
vollkommen verstehen
so dann kommen wir zu der
liebenfage was macht einen guten Blogger
aus nein Spaß was macht einen guten
Blogger aus ja man sollte schon ein
bisschen nicht nur vor der Kamera
sprechen und irgendwas erzählen man
sollte dennoch ein Konzept sich
ausdenken und man sollte auch versuchen
ein bisschen paar Effekte eventuell mit
einzubringen und das einfach einfach
anzusprechen die den Leuten gefallen und
die Leute auf Trab zuuhalten aber man
muss ja man muss ja man hat ja ganz
wenig Mittel eigentlich nur ne ja das
stimmt man hat ja man ist jetzt bei sich
zu Hause vor der Kamera was muss man tun
also ich es gibt viele Videos aber viele
sind langweilig
ist es z.B bei dir die jumpcuts das
viele schneiden oder was ist so das
Geheimrezept also viel schneiden ist
natürlich auch gut das sollte man auch
machen äh falls man so ein kleiner
Perfektionist ist wie ich und natürlich
hat man nicht viel bei sich zu Hause man
kann sich immer wieder Requisite kaufen
alles ein bisschen ja Spann gestalten
und über Themen reden die wirklich
aktuell sind wie schon erwähnt und wenn
man es locker macht wenn man Spaß Spaß
dran hat und die Leute anspricht dann
wird man auch definitiv Erfolg damit
haben okay
gut weiter im Text wie viel willst du
alle ziehen oder alle natürlich alle
roten und vielleicht zwei grüne
okay
so sehen Hüte nicht selten dämlich aus
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen Cowboys
ich finde die seenüten immer cool aus
also Cowboys die den stehenhüte immer
aber Cowboys in Zimmern aus dem aus der
aktuellen Zeit ich sieh immer ein
bisschen oder lä oder Frage anders
läufst du mit dem Hut auch draußen rum
ehrlich gesagt nicht also ich benutze
eher für meine Videos und ab und zu wenn
ich mal auf einem Festival bin wie z.B
Wacken oder so dann laufe ich gerne mit
dem Hut rum weil mein Hut z.B habe ich
auch aus Wacken und viele laufen da so
rum weil es einfach cool aussieht es ist
klar das ist zwar ein anderer Geschmack
aber ich persönlich find
stylisch okay fen wir dem nächsten Mal
Kar Lagerfeld
dazu ist eine gute Idee oder Chuck
Norris ich meine jauck Norris kann es ja
auch bestätigen der wir ja ja der wird
bestätigen natürlich warum bist du so
toll wie soll man darauf antworten genau
das ist persönlich das das ist eine
Frage da kann man elich gar nicht drauf
antworten also ich persönlich finde mich
nicht toll aber wenn ihr mich toll
findet dann finde ich euch auch
toll super sehr schön so du kannst mich
übrigens immer angucken bei den Fragen
aber müsste ich ja sagen dass du toll
bist das darf nein
nein das darfst du natürlich darfst du
das ja natürlich wenn du das
sagst Ali warum wirst du immer
schlechter ach das ist so eine Frage die
bekomme ich letzte Zeit öfter zu hören
Leute ich ge doch mein bestes ich
versuche wirklich meine Videos so gut
wie möglich zu gestalten en und ihr
könnt mir auch Tipps geben also wenn ihr
wenn ihr irgendwas merkt also wenn ihr
merkt dass ich da ein bisschen
missgebaut habe dann sagt es mir gibt
mir konstruktive Kritik und ich werde
versuchen meine Videos besser zu
gestalten siehst du ich höre auf meine
Fans super das ist gut sollte man aber
ich höre auch auf die Klicks und Fans
ich habe dich eingeladen
in in in wo klickst du Fangruppe oder
was nein ach die Leute sagen ja hey lad
malbl das kommt ja immer wieder unten
drunter ich mach zwar auch so Umfragen
mal aber da Gewinn immer Rapper ich kann
nicht immer Rapper ein
warum denn nicht vielleicht vielleicht
werde ich ja auch einer komme ich wieder
ey das wäre geil das ist die ideale der
erste Youtuber der Rapper wird ja klar
warte bin ich wirklich der erste es gibt
do nein es gibt Mörder nicht aber der
erste von der erfolgreich geworden ist
ohne Rap auf Youtube und dann anfängt zu
rappen das wäre schon das erste Mal so
die nächste Frage was tust du gegen
deine dönersucht gar nichts warum sollte
ich was gegen meine dönersucht tun jeder
liebt Döner und ich habe anscheinend
wirklich den besten Döner in Hamburg
gefunden im lapanese okay muss mal
probieren aber viele Leute sagen ja
Mustafas gemüsegrill in Berlin soll der
Beste sein und den werde ich mir auf
jeden Fall den werde ich mir auf jeden
Fall mal anschauen weil da stehen die
Leute wirklich Schlange bis zu 30
Minuten um diesen Döner zu probieren und
mal schauen jetzt habe ich
Schleichwerbung gemacht nee unter also
du darfst sowas sagen außerdem sind wir
hier nicht so streng und das zweite ist
schlimm ist es wenn du dafür Geld
kriegst und das ständig machst nein ach
was und es nicht sagst dass du Geld
dafür bekommst dann ist es wenn man sagt
hier Leute Mustafas gemüsegrill hat mich
mal gebeten zu sagen er ist toll also
Mustafas gemüsegrill der ist toll dann D
auch ke sch aber D ist ja auch wenn du
es vorher gesagt hast das ist ja Jael
Geld bekommstich dafür dass muss was
gemüsegrill
erwähnst also wenn sowas in solchen
Videos passiert ist das nie bezahlt
liebe Leute das wird wenn das wird viel
subtiler
gemacht die Leute gehen dann in ihren
Vlogs immer bei Mustafas gemüsebrill
essen z. must gemüsegrill ist toll ich
liebe mustfas gemüsegrill nein Spaß
beiseite spaß beiseite keine Ahnung ich
war da noch nie was macht dich so
einzigartig boah ich habe keine Ahnung
also ich bleibbe halt e ich selbst ich
bin ein Individuum wie wie jeder andere
auch es sein man ist Mitläufer aber ich
würde nicht unbedingt behaupten dass ich
Mitläufer bin also ich ziehe immer mein
eigenes Ding durch ich bin derjenige der
auch gerne im Mittelpunkt steht und na
ja ich bin nicht gab so ein Moment in
der Pubertät wo du wo so eine
Entscheidung getroffen hast wie du wirst
daran kann ich mich nicht erinnern ich
weiß nur wo ich anfä Videos zu machen
und das war wegen dem Kanal smch habe
ich ein bisschen bisschen nachgemacht
auf billige Art und Weise kann man sagen
und irgendwann habe ich dann meine eigen
Ideen entwickelt und ja es ist natürlich
nicht schlimm Vorbilder zu haben das
sollte man auf jeden Fall mal haben also
muss man nicht aber kann man haben und
meine Vorbilder waren damals halts morch
und ich habe mich nach den wirklich
orientiert kannte man sagen und aber da
war ja wie alt warst du da wie alt war
ich da 14 ja vollkommen okay also da
muss man sagen also liebe Leute wenn ihr
dann was nachmachen wollt macht das ist
ein super super Übung super Fingerübung
genau und ein guter Einstieg um selber
irgendwann spä was zu entwickeln man
wird damit nicht in den riesen Erfolg
haben wenn man was nachmacht aber ähm
man übt genau man übt und man wird
besser man kriegt seine eigenen Dinger
rein und dann macht man seine eigenen
Dinger auf Youtube und dann bekommt man
die Frage gestellt bist du wirklich so
geldgeil wie alle
sagen genau ja klar bin ich Geld geil
ich meine wer ist es nicht ich meine
alle Leute gehen zur Arbeit um Geld zu
verdienen oder oder wollt auf der Straße
leben aber Geld geil in dem Sinne dass
ich jetzt total fixiert auf Geld bin das
ist natürlich nicht so aber jeder hat
natürlich Interesse Geld zu verdienen
und das sollte man persönlich nicht
unbedingt verschleiern und sagen das
Leben besteht nur aus Luft und Liebe wer
braucht schon Geld und sitzt dann hier
vorne am See und
isst
Möhren oder
Möwen
ja nein man muss ja auch sagen wer auf
youtube ist kann nicht Geld gean sein
weil die Amerikaner die machen richtig
Kohle aber das ist hier in Deutschland
schon schwierig ja klar ist natürlich
schwierig und
aber es ist dennoch nicht dabei einfach
zu sagen hey ich möchte auch Geld damit
verdienen man ist ja nicht gleich
geldgeil nur wenn man Geld verdienen
will geldgeil das Wort an sich gibt es
auch gar nicht es ist so eine
Definitionssache was geldgeil ist
geldgeil für mich persönlich wäre dann
z.B wenn man
wirklich nur fixiert auf das Geld ist
und den Spaß komplett ausschaltet und
nur wegen Fame irgendwas macht und ich
persönlich würde schon behaupten dass
ich noch Spaß in der Sache habe die ich
mache und deswegen bin ich auch nicht
geldgeil also aber in dem Sinne dass ich
Geld verdienen möchte falls es jemand
für jemanden die Definition ist dann bin
ich geldgeil wobei in erster Linie und
das ist auf Youtube gar nicht anders
möglich muss einem das Spaß machen man
muss Leidenschaft haben wer geldgeil ist
auf YouTube wird nie Erfolg genau das
ist das Problem weil wenn man wirklich
am Anfang nur den Fame bzw das Geld in
den Augen hat dann wir man irgendwann
merken hey ich werde gar nicht so
schnell erfolgreich D hat man keine
keine Lust mehr drauf und probiert was
anderes weil man quasi ja sehr
ungeduldig und wenn man Spaß dran hat
dann gibt es keine Geduld oder Ungeduld
dann macht man es
einfach gut super gut ich danke dir
vielmals gleichs ich hoffe ihr hattet
eine Menge Spaß bei dem Fragenlotto mit
iBlali den werdet ihr sicher auch bei
dem mit den Atzen haben die erklären
warum jeder ein Atze sein will und auch
nicht von schlechten Eltern ist das mit
White Titi wo sie erklären wer von ihnen
der süßeste ist also bis dann bleib
dran